potestas today our car Chester Sasha
clamp will examine the new Honda Civic
with a 1.6 liter diesel engine up till
now
Honda hasn't played much of a role in
Germany and 2013 it's sold less than 23
thousand vehicles figures for Europe as
a whole look a little better almost
150,000 cars sold but globally Honda is
a major player selling 4.3 million autos
a year now Honda is presenting the Civic
tourer tailored to the German market in
a bid to boost sales here but can't
compete with a VW covariant budget sized
info vegan tot that's one month or two
and so on the Civic tourer is design is
much more dynamic than most hatchbacks
nothing solid or square here
the tour distinguishes itself well from
the crowd both in front and in the rear
we especially like the broad wheel wells
but the Turris design reduces the
drivers ability to see all around Sasha
says Honda serious interest in the
German market is shown by the trunk one
of the largest in this class it holds
624 liters and when you put the seat
down 1668 liters it has an additional
compartment under a hatch on the trunk
floor Sasha also likes the low trunk
sill just 55 centimeters which makes it
easier to load the potato mr. Adam are
comin from centimeter on the road the
tours dynamic appearance is matched by
its dynamic handling the steering is
precise and the engine is spirited
that's partly due to its 300 Newton
meters of torque but also to its light
weight the 1.6 liter diesel engine
weighs 50 kilograms less than the 2
liter engine it replaces Sasha likes the
crisp precise transmission
he says what's special about the Honda
Civic turb is its adaptive undercarriage
most adaptive axle systems involved all
the wheels the Civic tourer regulates
only the rear axle because Honda assumes
that the weight on the front axle will
remain the same but since up to 500
kilograms can be loaded at the rear its
burden here can vary widely
so the tour's axles can be adjusted
between three settings normal dynamic or
comfort as required for leg long the
Civic tourer is interior has a sporty
modern feel the overall appearance is
convincing but the large number of
buttons on the center console is a bit
confusing
Sasha points out a rare feature have you
ever tried to transport a bicycle in
your car in the Honda Civic Tour you
don't have to rearrange the trunk you
just hold the back seat upward and
there's room for a bicycle the Civic
Tour has many details that German
customers will like no wonder it was
developed for the European market and
this Japanese car is actually British
and rolls off the assembly line in
Swindon in southwestern England Sasha
isn't happy that the engine can be heard
during the entire Drive but it's not so
loud that it's really bothersome an eco
button on the dashboard lets you see how
ecologically you're driving according to
the position of the gas pedal and allows
you to regulate it accordingly being
green is the declared goal of the 1.6
liter diesel engine in the earth dreams
technology series Honda says the Civic
tours normal diesel consumption is 3.8
liters / 100km
only 99 grams of co2 emissions per 100
kilometers is pretty good too
the diesel hatchback cost twenty one
thousand five hundred fifty euros invest
a little more and Honda throws in a few
assistant systems including automatic
distance control and an emergency brake
assist Sascha sums up the Honda Civic
tourer clearly demonstrates that it's a
viable alternative to the VW golf that's
more storage space than any other
vehicle in this segment its price is
comparable to that of the Gulf so you
have to be prepared to spend quite a bit
but you do get value for your money